ah bon alors mais pourriez vous marier
avec bernard montée qu'est ce qu'elle
aime c'est vrai ça fait un couple
magnifique ouais franchement vraiment
vous et regardez beaux-arts regardez
regardez comment vous serez dans 30 ans
mais c'est ça la baisse et font regarder
le soleil connaît c'est fou en tout cas
s'il m'appelle pas vendredi voilà j'ai
aussi un cocon fait un drame parce qu'à
me fais la gueule c'est pourquoi
vraiment parce que c'est ma faire
charrier voilà non mais elle en valait
le vote sur tous les dossiers et qu'il
faut tout qu'aucun fan
du pénis
alors bernard est très bon très très
beau a poussé à oui je trouve très beau
père n'a pas vraiment elle est
magnifique
tu dis ça pour le jeu parce que tu ne
penses vraiment la ville elle est
vraiment j'adore ça non mais là c'est
vrai et à mathieu tu abuses avait
été marié ben oui on craignait pour rien
toi
[Rires]
en
tout cas ça me fait très plaisir qui est
un un couple qui se crée vraiment serait
le premier couple tnt a prédit
officiellement et rigide
non mais c'est vrai non mais vraiment
guillaume ça va vous êtes un petit peu
le fruit de cet amour ouais tu t'es bien
comment on a beau couple non mais c'est
vrai vous auriez peut-être sur leurs
enfants c'est vrai un froissement
parce que
il a 29 ans
ça peut être le mien non c'est pas
possible a pas mal même
blague il avait directement cette taille
puisse à un
truc de fou ah bon je croyais qu'il
avait mon âge non non
guillaume est un ami
syrie il ya eu la cérémonie du ballon
d'or et du et isabelle est vraiment
jalouse un abécédaire gagne encore 1
s'est fourré je vais demander en loge
avant est ce que je peux demander bat
bernard pas demander comment dire je
peux pas tout dire là ce soir mais
allégé pas répondu
avec qui ne dit rien consent un chéri
des périmètres lie à leiria les
téléspectateurs lors
il ya un problème on a mis le doigt fin
même pas le droit
on a soulevé un lièvre j'ai l'impression
que isabelle soulevé pécho bernard
authié
ses plateaux nous mais il faut me
demander d'autoriser sa
mamie nous on en a déjà parlé c'est
qu'elle allait elle est bloquée avec son
mari qu'elle aime beaucoup mais le
prénom cicala et maxi rance et des
sentiments qui se développe pour bernard
et là aussi c'est que du sida elle veut
pas le laisser s'échapper avec le garder
pour lui
son baryton quand sa pile à l'heure mais
vous avez d'infos mais elle veut rien
faire avec bernard reste pour alain mais
elle a beaucoup de jus lassonde sony
c'est cette affaire oui je la connais
c'est vrai que isabelle et très
exclusive alors ya un an c'était moi et
depuis c'est vraiment bernard et je
gardais jamais son mari
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cette entrave sexualisé moi qui ne
demande rien je suis très flatté par
tout ça mais c'est vrai vous avez avec
les amis de cotte vous saurions jamais
notre quote
je ne rêve pas gilles tu connais c'est
cette affaire guillaume est ce que tu as
entendu parler cette affaire d'isabelle
qui a déchiré bernard mottais dans
secret il ya des gros bruits de couloirs
secrets en ce moment donc en train
d'enquêter que les équipes reliant les
verts l'ont très rapidement ça va vous
sinon le réveil s'est bien passé
8h54 faudrait songer à trèbes et y est
quand même très peu dans ma que oui je
sais très bien qu'il ya autour de
sexualité chez mamie
alors atteint l'âge absolument pas noir
de la rue petit regard coquin tu vois
d'accord et à tire la tronche quand il
lui met des plans le midi quand il mange
ensemble ouais ouais
oui régulièrement et le vendredi à tous
les vents qui laisser sa chemise oui
pourquoi parce que messi maggie mais je
savais que là parce que moi j'aurais
alors je vous le dis moi j'aimerais
mélange très peu aux chroniqueurs non
mais c'est vrai je vais donc j'ai décidé
oui je découvre un petit peu je savais
pas du tout qu'il y avait un vrai bail
entre isabelle et berna ouais je croyais
que c'était une barca mais c'est vrai
elle est vraiment venir oui on est loin
d'être sa chose sexuelle c'est sa chose
spirituelle d'accord le problème c'est
qu'elle ressent de plus en plus un
besoin de sa personne au quotidien
système inter galactique
les choucas c'est toi
ce qui se passe et donc c'est vrai
isabelle est ce que vous avez un petit
truc pour bernard alors sexuellement
c'est mon mari c'est vraiment le plus
fort amicalement j'ai un droit de
cuissage sont bernard oui de drogue
douceur
voilà tchatche un objet sexuel oui mais
les nouveaux génère mais je vous ai dit
c'est sa chose dont elle ne supporte pas
que ou une femme tourne autour de
bernard qu'elle n'est pas le son mot à
dire dans l'histoire et c'est donc elle
se sent mise de côté donc il faut
qu'elle soit dans le bas là elle fait
partie du duo qui devient trio du cru et
c'est fou non il est vrai il est vrai
que j'ai plus que de la tendresse pour
isabelle
attendre c'est tu sais l'amitié l'amour
c'est très pro l'animal
était normal échangiste
remake mais ils sont vraiment il ya un
petit truc ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
la mise à belz et quand je suis avec
elle je suis très heureux mais avec le
rang social laurence en train de
commencer à faire la gueule ouais non
mais c'est pas ça je me dis que le vrai
scoop c'est ça c'est que tu aimes
isabelle voilà non c'est de vrai scoop
ce qui vous met au même niveau
[Rires]
on n'est pas qu'on parle d'autre chose
on avance à bernier
isabelle
n'étaient pas mariés ce que vous aurez
peut être avec elle on a failli à 30 ans
1 ouais les mecs alors moi
qui a mal tourné
ça c'est vrai quoi non c'est vrai
qu'est-ce qu'elle même avait interviewé
j'ai quand même les super canon alors
déjà elle avait les décolletés jusque là
ma l'époque c'était un peu plus
enveloppé et
si à peine si tu avais un peu plus de
cinq ans maintenant et
c'est sûr et c'est sûr il ya une
croyance et que je viens ici si elle
avait déjà les chemisiers ouvert jusque
là matin louis champod vsd ouais et
j'étais très séduits rigolote brillante
sympathique agréable et on s'est vus
puis voilà c'est tout moi c'est tout
voilà quoi non s'il briguait un
travailleur il ya eu ce but il n'y a pas
de problème on s'est vu régulièrement
non mais les mecs les mecs là on vient
d'apprendre quelque chose je le dis aux
téléspectateurs parce qu'à mon avis sont
vraiment péché même assurer certaines
heures après 11 ans qu'isabelle est une
chaudière
parce que c'est clairement mon mari m'a
porté déjà tout mais c'est vrai que si
jamais non et aimar
allez encore tout depuis le début
à l'inter des [ __ ] de gaffes là et
donc vous avez vu plusieurs fois oui
régulièrement il n'y a jamais eu autant
s'est retrouvé chez vous quelques temps
plus tard il se moque mais non même pas
non ici or même pas non parce que c'est
bizarre il vivait cette femme était très
occupé déjà ce moment-là mossi donc
c'était compliqué voilà et vous savez
quoi mais
rien
c'est très lourd trois vidéos game
après ça on peut pas dire qu'ils
ignoraient carrière
mais c'est vrai si y'a qu'à québec vidéo
gag la une est à vous tous les samedis
après midi en direct ça laisse du temps
non il y avait du bois ni
modéliste l'art était pâle était au top
comme maintenant non non c'était les
mecs sont produits à mon avis il ya eu
un lait mais qu'ai-je fait une
quotidienne tu porteras paddle tous les
jours
on avait bien enregistré 5 de la journée
non c'est enrichissant même si sa voix
la voix leur a promis de taper dessus
pendant une semaine la femme bien dans
les six émissions par jour
je suis pas fini de saper le temps c'est
que t'as pas envie à un
moment où je suis
tellement de générer les gérer un truc
les chéris c'est sûr qu'il ya un truc
pareil là tu crois c'est bon on le sait
maintenant regardez comme ils se
regardent
tous les souvenirs qui reviennent à
l'aider que tous les souvenirs qui
reviennent dit que et qu' il a fait très
froid aujourd'hui nos ouvreurs l'année
20 minutes parker ne sais pas ça c'est
sûr mais regardez
c'est sûr est génétiquement isabelle
lemay qui a le nez qui s'allonge du
monde tu me isabelle tilmant il amènera
à l'est dit que j'ai vu la réaction
qu'il a eue ça y est t'es sur le bail de
bernard montiel mais les français l'a
pas les abeilles ça va te faire du bien
de le dire c'est vrai nous faire du bien
à part avec mariage est un pas rentrer
c'est pas grave zapatero nazon garderie
pardonnera saillie ça il doit il aussi
ou pas ah oui oui de ce fait le coup y'a
presque puisque j'aime beaucoup bernaoui
a en plus il court le mari ben non non
non non
quoi ce que oui ou non
je n'ai pas compris des questions vidéo
la lah avec un ménage suisse au c'est
pas moi c'est sûr c'est sûr c'est sûr et
c'est
incroyable ce qu'on vient d'apprendre on
dirait qu'ils ont à 12 heures ce soir ah
mais c'est sûr mais c'est bien ce que je
sais sur cinq dit je veux pas répondre à
pas dire qu'il est héros bat nathalie va
poser la question et c'est très gênant
parce que laurence le vert tout ça
cardy le bernard
iv tu ne peux pas leur mentir elle que
oui ou non on a déjà fait quelque chose
sexuelle on le sait la belle je ne
réponds jamais cela
sans gaz une autre personne qui n'est
pas moi je ne peux pas répondre à sa
personne je leur ai répondu c'est
l'arrêt ce fait la personne et la raison
tient la balle at il d'abord une
description lalanne a rien eu pour moi
y'a rien eu de ce genre vient moi y'a
rien lui il est à mon avis il aurait
voulu mais ils n'ont pas fait je vous
dis je connais ça c'est comme benhaim
avec moi elle voulait me paie chaud
pendant des années
justement parlons-en alors benhaim agi
avec quelque chose sur que non alors là
on a eu zéro d'août contrairement à toi
là bas au bénin quand il a fait chaud
mais aussi
[Rires]
les papas bénin
à l'arrêt choper n'avaient jamais touché
ces boulettes non
moi ça me rase et attendait non
messieurs
tous et les bouley donnez moi je sais
ces boulettes non rassurez moi non mais
alors là je vous le dis je suis bouche
bée alors ce qui s'est passé parce que
l'on se focalise sur isabelle et bernard
mais il ya une femme meurtrie l'un
qu'elle en a rien à carrer c'est
horrible je crois qu'il a pris le
moindre regard des ouais je mens en plus
ça fait vraiment plaisir de revoir ici
par ce duo est énormément manqué
mercedes et gestes
[Applaudissements]
ap st heureusement franck dubosc elie
semoun qui nous regardent ça nous fait
plaisir de te revoir
les séries en tout cas après ça est-ce
que vous avez autre chose avoué si l'on
peut démarrer les mythes chine est-ce
que tu as quelque chose à faire sinon si
tu as vu quelque chose au creux des deux
dit le
nom moi si j'avais été célibataire et
isabelle aussi on se remet à rêver
qu'une
tout ça mais les violences non mais
c'est pas possible mais ça c'est suzan
le slip en fait appel le 18 tu tombes
sur le site de ras al amoud et non mais
sans déconner
et alors ils s'appellent si toi
connard y avait dû choisir entre gilles
et berna pour une relation amoureuse et
sexuelle plus riches choisi un
politiquement bernard pourquoi pas une
croix basque avec gilles on se prendrait
le foot ou le thym non mais c'est
tellement c'est que le noir est
sexuellement ont vraiment posée y avez
vous aviez montré des photos de lui il
ya dix ans tout nu avec un petit côté
hugues aufray a pas mal du tout hein ah
oui
mais c'est un beau pas fait
c'est pas tout mais ça ferait du thouet
plus bernard vient vous dire que c'était
moi oui elles ne meurent n'ont ni à
l'autre vous voyez pas elle devait
garder les deux il abandonner les
abeilles sont gênés ou à trois on aurait
pu à 3
dans ce cas là je regarde un
ça va s'il est bien
un troupeau
jules et jim je suis le seul à coucher
que personne
n'en soyez tout dépend si tu as un peu
le public mais ça va vous sinon que
feriez vous si vous deviez choisir
quelqu'un ce serait bien d'un bouquet
entre kikito bernard montiel et castaldi
sont dans votre hanche au delà bernard
mais un chien ah ouais comment ça va
bien sûr
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vais poitrine chez les hommes si des
prud'hommes et c'est sincère mais je ne
le connais pas assez alors oui il est
sympa pourtant il faut bien deux ans de
discussions où nos ambitions
à deux ans des centres avec lui